we have a guest in studio wait waiting
patiently is Judge Jimmy Edwards who has
been with the st. Louis chess club and
scholastics helping us with our missions
there for so many years
he's with Maurice yes indeed a very
important person and even sitting around
patiently judge after all he had
patience and he is the director for
public safety in st. Louis area judge
tell us what inspires you to get into
the law field in the first place the
kind of contribution you could make but
Maurice I was born right here in the
city of st. Louis and just inspired by a
wonderful mom poor kid inner city st.
Louis who really understood that
education is the key to all of life's
rewards and so with that I thought that
being an attorney would give me an
opportunity to reach back into my
community and to help folk in my
community so law was the answer I
believe to in order to achieve some of
those things definitely admirable and we
know that the city has some challenges
we know about Ferguson we know about
Michael Brown we know the difficulties
that still persists today what do you
see as the way to implement change as
you give that contribution yourself well
certainly I think education and I was
very concerned about the school to
Prison Pipeline
as a judge I sit on the bench for 25
years prior to taking a job as the
Public Safety Director and one of the
assignments that I had was the juvenile
court and trying to rehabilitate
children inside of the juvenile courts
so way back in 2009 Rex and I got
together and we got together to
implement a chess program at a school
that I had developed in order to keep
kids in school and out of court and
since 2009 the st. Louis chess club has
just been awesome in terms of its
support of the school now that school is
the innovative concept Academy tell us
about what makes it so innovative well
what makes it innovative is that we take
children that nobody else wants we take
children that people thought could not
achieve anything
we teach them how to achieve not only do
we teach them the basics but we teach
them how to be decent and lower body and
one of the the things that we do is we
use chess and so in my mind chess is a
cerebral game it's a type of game that
requires people to think not one step
ahead but two or three steps ahead and
it's just like life the analogy that I
use with the kids you see in life if you
make the wrong move or if you move too
quickly you might lose your life in the
game of chess if you move too quickly
you might lose your queen and so think
before you act
or the lessons of chess and so that
lesson translate and transforms into
everyday life and because of that and
when I left the bench I was so impressed
with what was happening with our
children and the fact that they were
becoming more deliberate as they played
the game of chess I took it then to the
police department and so now today as
the Public Safety Director of the city
of st. Louis who has a responsibility of
all law enforcement in the city I'm
playing why not cops and chess and do
you do as chess cops program the chess
program we ourselves went to the kickoff
these are very exciting to go there to
actually see the police officers and
children playing chess knowing that
police officers go into the schools and
teach chess and they're being trained to
do so here and it serves many many
things for me one of the things of
course is it teaches children to be
cerebral as I indicated but what it also
does it creates a relationship between
police and community police and children
it closes to trust gap and so it's
important that our children grow up
understanding and respecting police
authority and so it serves a lot of
purposes while chess is a is one of the
greatest games ever but it serves a
different purpose for me it teaches that
that young child how to be respectful
see in chess we teach you at the end of
every game
win lose or draw you stand up and you
reach your hand out and you shake your
opponent's hands because when you shake
another man's hand it's a sign of
respect well very inspiring indeed I'm
gonna ask you do you play chess not a
very good chess player and when I sit in
front of you and I sit in this room
I'm awfully intimidated now Rex I might
be able to play that's what I'm talking
about
so much for all you do such great work
another good-looking black man all set
by the way snorting that Baldy well
thank you so much for everything you do
sincerely keep up the great work and
thank you for the good things that you
do in our city Maurice we appreciate you
judging Edwards in the Director of
Public Safety here in the st. Louis is a
very important job and using chess to
help change lives judge Edwards I just
have to ask for me or extraordinarily
well-spoken you're articulate you do you
teach public speaking I mean you should
be a professor public speaking the way
you represent so well you are very kind
I'm starting to wonder if I owe you any
money
compliment onset we've been asking the
people to go make confession as well as
person and yes and speaker so that's
obvious yes yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]